et oui c'est du jamais vu depuis cinq
ans le pays subit de plein fouet la
troisième vague de coronavirus et les
mesures en vigueur en février ce sont
plus de 45000 personnes qui se sont
inscrites au chômage
et parmi elles plus des deux tiers
travailler dans le secteur des services
alors il faut rappeler contre les
restrictions mobilité et les fermetures
imposée par le gouvernement espagnol
pour freiner la propagation de
coronavirus les bars les restaurants
mais aussi l'hôtellerie et le tourisme
sont fortement touchées dans le pays
en ce début d'année l'agriculture est
également impactée tandis que
l'industrie reste stable alors parmi les
quatre millions de chômeurs ils ne
prennent pas en compte les 900 milles
personnes qui sont encore au chômage
partiel en espagne à l'automne le
premier ministre pedro sanchez avait
déjà annoncé la création de 800 mille
postes de travail en trois ans pourtant
le pib en 2020 s'est effondré de 11%
c'est l'un des pires résultats de la
zone euro alors désormais tous les
regards sont portés vers le mois d'avril
où les secteurs espèrent une reprise de
l'activité et une en relâchement des
mesures pour une reprise du tourisme